[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is
paul today's topic is the scots language
scots is a language spoken in scotland
one of the constituent countries of the
united kingdom
right off the bat it's important to
point out that there are essentially
three different languages in scotland
scottish english
scots and garlic garlic is a celtic
language that is only distantly related
to english and scots as an indo-european
language
scots and scottish english on the other
hand are closely related to each other
though they're not the same thing
scottish english is for the most part
standard english but spoken with a
scottish accent scots on the other hand
is distinct
having diverged from a dialect of middle
english and having features that differ
from english
some people consider scots to be a
separate language while others consider
it to be a historical dialect of english
just like the historical dialects found
in england but we'll get into that a
little bit later
according to the 2011 scottish census
just over 1.5 million people speak scots
around 30
of the scottish population history
the roots of scots lie in northumbrian
old english one of several old english
dialects
northumbrian old english was being
spoken by the 7th century
in the anglo-saxon kingdom of
northumbria which was located in
northeastern england and part of the
scottish lowlands
the kingdom of scotland was founded in
the year 843
with the unification of the pictish
people and golic speaking scots
but english-speaking northumbrian lands
were not yet part of the kingdom
when the northern part of northumbria
finally became part of scotland in the
11th century
golic became the prestige language of
the area but english remained the most
widely spoken language
the variety of english spoken there may
have been significantly influenced by
norse because the southern part of
northumbria
along with much of northern and eastern
england had been under danish control
and its english dialects had been
influenced by norse and scandinavian
settlers were also present beyond the
border of that area as well
in the 12th and 13th centuries during
the middle english period
the borough system of administrative
division led to the spread of english
further into scotland
borahs were autonomous urban communities
where traders merchants and craftsmen
could live and do business in exchange
for paying taxes on their earnings
the boroughs were ruled by nobles who
answered to the king
they attracted economic migrants from
other parts of scotland including gallic
speaking areas from
england especially from areas that had
been under danish control where norse
influenced dialects were spoken
and from farther away places like
flanders frisia
and scandinavia english became the
common language of the boroughs but the
multilingual environment
created by the economic migrants had an
influence on the language
so as english became more widespread in
scotland because of the boros
it also began to diverge from
northumbrian middle english
other influences were latin because of
its role as the ecclesiastical language
and the language of laws and
record-keeping
and norman french because of the
influence of king david the first
who had close ties with norman england
the divergent variety of middle english
that grew out of these influences
is now referred to as early scots but at
the time it continued to be referred to
as english
until the end of the 15th century in the
14th and 15th centuries
english replaced garlic in much of the
lowlands as well as replacing
french as the administrative language as
well as replacing latin as the language
of records and law
another thing that happened in the 15th
century was that the orkney islands and
the shetland islands came under scottish
rule
scandinavian settlers had been living on
these islands since the 9th century
and spoke a language called norn that
derived from old norse
but scot-speaking settlers began to move
there and the prestige language became
scots
from this contact new dialects of scots
would develop with more norse influence
than other forms of scots
these dialects are shetland scots and
arcadian scots
or orkney by this point scots had become
fairly distinct from english as spoken
in england
one thing that set them apart was that
the southern english dialect of london
was becoming the standard in england
whereas scots had more in common with
the northern dialects
another thing that set them apart was
the great vowel shift the great vowel
shift
took place between the years 1350 and
1600
more or less and caused vowels of
english to be pronounced differently
this also affected scots although the
specific changes were different
and some vowels that changed in english
remained unchanged in scots
for example in middle english the
letters o u
represented the sound u in southern
english and thus
in standard english this sound shifted
to au
but in scots it remained unchanged so
today
in standard english you say mouse but in
scots you say
moose moose i'm not a moose and a brown
cow in english
is a brunku in scots who knew
the great vowel shift took place at
about the same time that english
orthography was becoming standardized so
that english spelling
often reflected earlier middle english
pronunciation
and it still does today scots on the
other hand was written more freely to
reflect the way
it was really pronounced an extensive
body of scots literature was written in
the 15th and 16th centuries but towards
the end of that time period as english
was growing in prestige
scots was increasingly being written
using a combination of scots and
english spellings when king james vi of
scotland became the unified monarch of
england and ireland in 1603
and began to rule from london the
influence of english continued to grow
with the scottish upper classes adapting
and anglicizing their speech and writing
this is what ultimately led to the
development of scottish standard english
scots was still widely spoken by the
common people
but with the full union of england and
scotland in 1707
it became even more discouraged and
frowned upon
but the marginalization of scots caused
a rebound later that century
with the scots literary revival led by
poets such as alan ramsey
later robert burns widely considered the
national poet of scotland
wrote in a combination of vernacular
scots and scottish english
scots language literature declined once
again in the 19th century but
experienced revivals again in the 20th
century
poet hugh mcdermott attempted to create
a standard form of literary scots based
on a combination of different scots
varieties
later in the 20th century novels
narrated in scott's vernacular began to
appear
is scots a language or a dialect of
english
whether scots is a separate language or
a dialect can be a difficult question to
answer
especially because these days many
people use both of them
in combination with each other today
there's a diglossic situation
in which people in the scot speaking
areas can freely code switch between
scots and standard english
and combine them together in varying
degrees depending on the situation
so think about that for a second you
have scots and then you have standard
english which are very closely related
to begin with and people slide back and
forth between the two of them
stopping anywhere along the continuum
that suits the situation
in this kind of diglossic situation it's
easy to perceive both varieties as
registers of a single language to
perceive scots as a vernacular form of
english
but some people still see scots as a
language in its own right and they
typically point to the body of scots
literature from over the centuries
which remained divergent from the
conventions of standard english as it
developed
there's no universal standard for
determining what's a language and what's
a dialect
the classic quote is a language is a
dialect with an army and a navy
well scots began without an army then it
got one
then it lost it and maybe it will have
one again in the future
but the very least we can say is that
when scott's vernacular is spoken in
isolation
without using standard english it is
fairly distinct
so what is scott's like well it's a lot
like english
but the main difference is in the way
it's pronounced especially the vowels
of course there are many different
accents of english but scots has
distinct pronunciation of its own
and unlike english scots is written and
spelled to reflect the sounds of the
spoken language
so when you read scots the differences
become more obvious
scots also uses its own words and
expressions that are not a part of
english though some people may pepper
their speech with scott's words for
effect when they're speaking mainly
scottish english
let's look at a few examples of everyday
speech in scots
the pronunciation and the spelling
depends on the local variety but these
examples are from erisher in the
scottish lowlands
here's a sentence meaning the children
caught some insects in the garden
the burns caught some beasties in the
garden
right away you'll probably notice that
there are some non-english spellings
like
some and garden which is distinct in
pronunciation from garden
the first vowel is different and also
notice that the d is pronounced as a
glottal stop
but it's often pronounced that way in my
canadian dialect of english as well
we'd normally say garden not garden when
speaking naturally
you'll probably notice a couple of
different words here as well
there's barons instead of children this
word is not exclusively scots but is
also used in some english dialects of
northern england
then we have beasties instead of insects
this is an endearing form of the word
beast
which can be used to refer to small
animals or insects
here's a sentence meaning i went to the
shop with my little brother and sister
i went to the shop with my wee brother
and sister
here the first thing to notice is i went
this clearly isn't the definite article
ah
because it's followed by a verb this is
actually the first person singular
personal pronoun
like i in standard english next notice
te meaning to this can be pronounced te
on its own but here it's reduced to
sound like
just like it would normally be reduced
in an english sentence like this
as in i went to the shop we can hear the
full vowel sound in this word
wei which means with here ma means mai
we means little this word is found in
standard english in certain fixed
phrases like
a wee bit or the wee hours of the night
but it's originally a scots word
and in scots as well as scottish english
it's very common
notice the spelling of this word brither
which means brother
obviously the difference here is just a
difference in the vowel and vowels vary
like this
in various english dialects as well but
in scots they're actually spelled
differently
here in is a reduced form of and the
pronunciation of and is often reduced in
english too
but it would never be spelled like this
except maybe in a comic book or
something like that
here's a sentence meaning i can't go to
the party tonight because i've got a lot
to do
i can go to the party of the night
because i've got a lot to do
again we see ah meaning i here can a
means can't or can not
and here's te again notice the
equivalent word for party
which is pair e the first vowel sound is
different
and the t is pronounced like a glottal
stop not perti but
per e here notice that tonight is the
night in scots
which i find quite interesting because
in some other languages like hebrew and
arabic you say the night or the day
cause is a contraction of because this
is something that occurs in various
dialects of english including mine but
it would only be written like that in an
informal context
av is like ive in english and to do is
today
here's a sentence meaning i don't want
to go to work today because i haven't
got much energy
i didn't want to go to work the day
because i haven't got much energy
here's ah again i guess i should have
used sentences with some different
pronouns
oh well here's the word for don't deny
remember that can't was
kenney so this ending seems to be the
pattern for negative contractions
here we have tay again and here the word
for work is written the way it sounds
i think this is a clear case of the
great vowel shift causing a difference
between the spelling and the sound in
english
here we see that today is the day
similar to the night that we saw before
here's kaz again and here's another
negative contraction
haven't is all of those examples were
everyday modern examples but let's look
at something a little more literary and
traditional
this is an excerpt from a poem by the
scottish poet robert burns
who's often said to be scotland's
national poet the poem is called tama
shanter
which was written in 1790. by the way
tama shanter
is also what we call these scottish caps
these caps are named after the hero in
burns's poem
well here we go when chaplain billies
leave the street
and ruthie knieber's neighbours meet as
market days are waiting late
and folk begin to tack the gate while we
sit boozing at the nappy
getting through and unco happy we think
nian the lang scot smile
the mosses water slaps and styles
that lie between us and our home where
sits our silky sullen dame
gathering her brows like gathering
storms nursing her wrath to keep it warm
in the first line chapman billies means
peddlers or
traveling salespeople in the second line
drewthe means thirsty neighbors is
equivalent to neighbours
in the third line there are no
differences but to clarify the meaning
wearing late means getting late in the
fourth line tech the gate
means to take the road home or i suppose
to head home
so in lines one to four burns is
creating the image of people finishing
work and going home in the fifth line
boozing means boozing or drinking
alcohol nappy means liquor or
ale i guess at is used here in the same
way you might say
sipping at your drink in the sixth line
we have
foo which comes from the french word foo
meaning crazy
so getting foo means getting crazy or
getting drunk
anko means very it comes from the old
english word
unkuth meaning unknown or unusual so i
guess we could say that
uncle happy means unusually happy if we
want to dig into its etymology
in the seventh line we see a different
way of forming the negative
rather than dna think it's think nay i
think this is a poetic literary form the
same way you might write think
not in english rather than don't think
lang means long and a scot smile is a
unit of measurement
like a mile so this sentence says
something like we're not thinking about
the long walk home
in the eighth line mosses means marshes
slaps means steps styles means styles
as in steps that lead you over a fence
or a wall
and in the ninth line hem means home
so in lines five to nine burns is
creating the image of people getting
drunk and not thinking about their
journey home
in the ninth line we have a different
spelling for where and dame
means wife lines ten and eleven are the
same in english and in scots
in the tenth line there's the phrase
gathering her brows
i imagine her eyebrows are close
together because she's scowling
making an angry face in the 11th line
nursing her wrath to keep it warm
means that she is intentionally keeping
herself angry because she's planning to
scold her husband
so in lines 10 to 13 burns is creating
the image of an angry wife
sitting at home waiting for a
confrontation with her husband as soon
as he gets home
so in that poem we saw a little more of
a literary style of scots
again it's very much like english but it
has its own unique pronunciation
spelling and vocabulary
and in the earlier examples we saw some
unique word forms and contractions
do differences like that make scots a
separate language from english
according to a survey conducted by the
scottish government 64
of scottish people either slightly or
strongly agree that scots is not a
language
it's just a way of speaking and that
includes 58
of the people who speak scots most
frequently so even some scot speakers
don't really think of it as a language
and that brings me to the question of
the day for speakers of scots do you
think of scots as a language or as a
dialect or register of english
and also to what extent do you use scots
and for everyone else
how similar or different do scots in
english seem to you leave your comments
down below
be sure to follow langfocus on facebook
twitter and instagram
and as always i would like to say thank
you to all of my amazing patreon
supporters especially these magnificent
people
right here on the screen for their
monthly pledges thank you for watching
and have a nice
[Music]
day
[Music]
you